[Musik]
hallo leute ein ganz herzlich willkommen
auf dem kanal der welt sogar ein format
zu heftig deswegen werde ich wollte zehn
minuten gedauert
der eigentliche grund ist ich habe ein
video mit seiner aufgenommen allerdings
war ist ja immer dass er der der technik
heißt freundeskreis selber hat die der
eu null ahnung was vergessen mein mikro
anzuschalten
unsere ohne die stimme geht das video
nicht wir deswegen glück dass jetzt wir
haben eigentlich nicht lachen scheint
aufgenommen ich zeig euch mal wie die
tonqualität war kann meine hände nicht
bewegen
das heißt wenn jetzt ein bankräuber
reinkommt sagt hände hoch geld her dann
[Musik]
darf ich das video hochladen
dafür sehe ich meine dieses nicht lachen
ich hab's gelöscht ich habe standard oma
gedacht andere heute ein tag also nicht
von tag aber 14 minuten und kannst dich
hören wissen nicht was diese wand für
mich das macht mich unglücklich die so
warnt die kammer den verdacht mit 24
jahren gewartet voller kinder
es geht ja gar nicht hier erzeugen wir
über hier ist okay so haben dann hat die
schönen gesicht richtig erzählt luca
kindern dass in diesem sommer so ich
frage mich ab und zu lange zu erwachsen
kein wunder dass du gesagt es ist
unglaublich hier und da noch ein paar
kinder herausgebracht der jungen dagegen
auch gut wenn denn so kalt
dieses stück reicher wissen wie johann
der hand sieht man dieses mal keine
rolex kein gutes stück arbeit weil wir
sonst immer mit max ist ein bisschen
hart eingezogen ich bin weiß ich mich
gerade er hinzu was sag ich sag euch mal
den hilfen
folglich hallo wir übertreffen
weil wenn ich dann zahlen sie dann da
bin ich nicht mehr da ich habe den wagen
hier wir können nicht mehr machen doch
ich merke kommen ich habe dann war sie
traurig wir haben und zum video
aufgenommen wo wir auch wenig wütend
reagiert haben wir einfach vergessen die
tonaufzeichnung wasser
was ist bei uns im überfluss gibt ist in
tansania sehr knapp
in deutschland gibt es von 20 25 minuten
video einfach umsonst die nächste rolle
[Gelächter]
sagt immer er ist nicht so recht aber
erst so richtig zu finden wenn sammer
hat einfach ein paar tage auch ein video
hochgeladen ich nerve luca für zehn
minuten bei waren youtube.com bary auf
dem video ist sollte eigentlich
mainformat sein buch für ein tag
ausgeliehen der das format machen da die
küche hier
designer wie oft die chefs
was willst du denn leute haben ihren
zweiten geburtstag nur das nur mal so
nebenbei zu dürfen
damit ihr auch alle bisher da gerade
muss nächste woche steht die mit
normaler adressen küche paar geschenke
zu senden und luca noch mal zu sagen was
krieg ich zum händedruck du kannst mir
nicht nicht schenk sprachen lernen aber
ich habe auch gleich das re problem ich
kann sie stoppen luca lebt im kölner dom
so ganz rom ist lukas mein gesicht ist
jedoch schon die wellplatten dann
solange noch gestellt und das hast du
dann hatten wir die bürger drauf
dafür haben wir wert der bundeskanzler
angela merkels frühstücken geht einfach
mal markt frisst sich langsam sagen
selbst auch weiter oder ich werde zum
kann die listen und schließlich wieder
rein oder ich hab kein thermometer
polier gespielt luca ist so ein
beschissener verlierer alter der drei
einfach letzte bugs geworden und hat
dann den rest des abends mit keinem mehr
von uns gesprochen weil er so dumpf du
bist ein richtiges arschloch in ried
wird wieder mehr auf die flex auf das
monopoly spiel konzentriert sich aufs
nächste kauf ich mir dabei gedacht hat
die beamten so tief zu hängen also sein
dass man sich richtig schön dass man
sagen es ist einfach hier luca sagte
angeblich immer das ja auch designer
gerne wo will ich denke ich er ist
welche täglich denke ich auch nie genug
haben wir hier deine newport zu deiner
wohnung in arboga ordentlich werbung für
dich damit du nicht mäßige bleibt wo
macht zudem werbung für mich drei
positive eigenschaften von mir manchmal
müssen hier deine wohnung dass er neu
getauft haben
benutze ich nur daten bei denen ist
nicht als das teuer sorgen markt gute
sonos boxszene hab mich ein biologe
konnte luca ich bin derjenige gar nicht
benutzt seit jahren hin
da habe ich überall die bambus hier
stehen weil ich möchte eigentlich im
kader als haustier haben erlaubt mir
aber meine mutter nicht klar
ihr wisst ihr ich wollte etwas spenden
aber war leider nur euro
zusammenbekommen
sorry leute ich kann nicht spenden das
ist schon für die machen wenn mit den
mitbürgern machten mir habe kanister zu
sehen
klagen macbook hier
das ist ein macbook mac die auf macbook
herum sondern hat james blunt sehe ich
auch hier auch schon klar hier in ecke
versteckt als eine gute sache näher kam
einmal jährlich zu können macht lukas
rover sport genauso man wird der sport
die auch schrecklich schrecklich dass
sie aus valencia auf mich gestellt
dieses ich hab ich noch nie gesehen
da kommt ein paar sekunden später nicht
aus
[Musik]
du wurdest du brauchst du gar nicht mehr
ich kann ja man ist hier zeigen die
macht lukas sachen die füße shades of
grace luca du bist du sehen eigentlich
eine decke ein bisschen das ist so ende
unterschied weil du kann mir wer
tagesmutter steht eine frage
als teilnehmer gesucht
weißt du nicht aus er könnte recht haben
wenn ich jetzt morgen sterbealter komm
mal her ich zeig euch mal wie staub ich
seit leben ist manchmal da drauf
da das nicht in den saal kommt offenbar
nicht genug nach 19
mehr gleichen content lokale daher war
es gut gemacht hat
das wasser ziehen kombi oder das was
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und
belgischen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]